[Music]
hello guys and welcome to a super cult
production of congratulations
[Music]
dude it's awesome man um
the guy's writing me here let me figure
this out um
okay all right cool
um all right dude yeah dude i get texts
whatever what do you want to what do you
want what do you want from me i get
texts and sometimes i need to check them
and that's how it goes
and uh you know that's me being
respectfully me for for that ass so so
thank you for listening this is uh you
know congratulations episode whatever it
is i'm not in the business account in
the episodes um but uh i'm here and man
let me just tell you let me actually
start off by saying first of all we got
merch out there we got the brown
shits and the periwinkle shits out there
and the life rips
you know it's brown whatever we'll put
some slides up here but um we uh it's
all out crystalia.com and uh but we've
got exclusive merch from the
shows that you can only get live at the
shows and this [__] was selling like
[__] vaccines dude it was selling
like uh lycovetes i should say is what i
mean
cause those had a really big those
surged over the past few years you know
what i mean
um but yeah dude uh we i played a few
venues already i did dallas and i did
wichita before i even start telling you
about that let me tell you i will be in
dc washington dc crystalia.com i'll be
in atlanta too that's sold out there's
still some tickets left to washington dc
and i'll be in stockton and
uh oakland
there
so get your tickets at crystalia.com
stockton oakland and also um washington
dc
can't wait to play really the nation's
capital you know that's just me being
i'm not even political but that's just
like me kind of like you know i just you
know
i'm american dude you know
what was i proud to be an american an
amazing number right some lose but what
i always say is you're either an
american or an american and i'm an
american not an american
um so yeah so that's where i'll be uh
oakland and then i got a hollywood
california date at the
improv there i'm just gonna do chris lee
and friends peoria rockford illinois
raleigh north carolina and then i added
a temp arizona just so i'm going to do
some i'm going to be out there in
phoenix thanks so i'm going to go do
some shows in tempe while i'm there at
the tempe improv
uh yeah man it's been fun dude i was uh
let me just thank you for being here man
uh
thank you for listening i'm feeling very
grateful for today you know um
grateful that you're here listening
and i just uh i want to thank you man
this is great and i still can't see if
you're with me last time last week told
you my eyes were blurry and my eyes are
still blurry dude and that's just how
it's gonna be i guess
um i thought it was from maybe some
crying that i was doing but it wasn't
necessarily from some crying i was doing
because i didn't cry today
and uh my contacts are definitely just
blurry so i won't be able to read the
screen on the computer yes dude that's
awesome man
[__] yeah i love when i can't see [__]
um
you know i'm sure all this flying you
know took took a few flights man took a
few flights doesn't help wore contacts
for extended periods of time shouldn't
people say i should get lasik
not going to get lasik because that
means there will be lasers in my eyes
and if there's an earthquake while i get
lasers in my eyes
just [__]
and then [__]
a whole shit's like that [__] scene
from um
what's that uh [__]
uh video resident evil when the
[__] lasers go through the guy and
it's
and it just splits them
in that room you know what i'm talking
about if you're a [__] dork um and
i'm a dork
do you know that scene ivan ivan knows
it well we dorks
um so yeah um
so i took a bunch of flights i flew out
to dallas
dallas i flew out to dallas in one of
the shows and crystallized shows dallas
and um
you know i flew out there and i met uh
kristen and calvin there and it was so
awesome i got a the tour report coming
out here on my youtube on my other
channel on the crystalia youtube channel
um but yeah i met with calvin and
kristen and it was awesome man because i
was away from my family for like two or
three days because she went to st louis
to visit some friends and took calvin
with him with her and then uh
and then went to and then met me in
dallas and it's awesome man it's awesome
to see your son in a different state
it's just so cool man like you're like
oh dude this guy's got like my son's
been to wichita dude that's hilarious
he's [__] two and a half and my son's
just been to kansas dude
just born in beverly hills
[__]
been to kansas
i've never been i'll tell you what when
i showed up to wichita
do you know when i i i
i knew i don't even know if i've been
playing i've been on the road to so many
different places i don't know if i've
been to these places before and i get
there and i'm like wichita [__] yeah and
then i can tell by the crowd reaction or
if they tell me afterwards or the driver
on the way there
they'd be like i'll be like have i been
here before and they're like yeah you've
been there
you came three years ago
for the [__] no pain set and i was
like oh really i don't know and then i
get there and the [__] guy
in charge he's like welcome back and i'm
like [__] yeah and then another person's
there is like yeah you never came here
before so who knows it's up in the air
but
um
the guy in charge said i went and the
driver said i went that she drove me
before so that's good uh but i did the
dallas show and my god dude you can see
on the on the video i put out um on the
tour report video i put out on on
youtube uh the crowd was just amazing
dude
you know we sold a bunch of tickets and
um it was beautiful and i didn't know
that this was gonna happen afterwards
but kristen was over in the wings with
calvin and he sat and watched the whole
[__] show
and afterwards
i looked over at him and my son just
comes walking out and runs up to me and
i grabbed him and it was the sweetest
[__] thing and there's video of it
and in the video if i slow it down i
could see him see me and then run to me
and right before i i grab him he smiles
dude and it's so [__] cute that he
smiles at the hug
it's beautiful man
and i thanked everybody and they [__]
uh
they're they're just great man thank you
for coming out dallas you guys are
[__] awesome and then i flew to
[__] wichita and the flight was too
early yeah baby but then i
dude the flight was too early and um you
know
we put calvin down and yeah he got about
six hours or no i guess it was like
seven hours of sleep not so bad you know
for me a travesty but for him he's a you
know he but he can buck up and uh for me
as a travesty if i get any less than
nine hours a day don't talk to me dude
sincerely don't talk to me
uh it's rough yo turn me down to the
headphones a little bit pee diddy tell
me down in the headphones and so uh if i
get anywhere less than nine hours uh
don't talk to me seven for real seven no
do not talk to me i'm more like it's so
it's so awful
i need at least eight and so
we got up we packed we got in the
[__] airplane
uh flight was like 40 minutes
and uh
did that
and then did wichita now let me tell you
about wichita dude wichita
sold out awesome show [__] i've been
there before it turns out
and the btk killers from there of course
i did a bunch of minutes up top talking
about the
dk killer um
and uh
yeah it's crazy that that's its claim to
fame
because btk killer killed a bunch of
people in wichita and park
city kansas
between
1974 and 1990 1971 and 1994 so and then
he stopped and then he couldn't he
couldn't help himself and then in the
2000s he started writing uh journalists
how he's a bt killer and then he got
caught so it all catches up with you so
uh and i know that because i did some
research so i do research and um
and that's that so i did the wichita
shows and they [__] gave me a
standing ovation dude and they gave me a
standing ovation in dallas of course
naturally and before and after ended
very sweet and i got very emotional but
wichita gave me one in
[Laughter]
the middle dude and i told i told i
texted to brian cowan i was like yo dude
do you ever get a standing ovation in
the middle and uh he said no because you
know he doesn't and he doesn't even get
him in the beginning or the end but i do
and it's all good my babies and we had a
good time and he says yeah i don't care
dude i said yeah but dot dot dot you
ever get him in the medal and uh
you know
felt good dude love wichita i should
have shot my [__] honestly i should
have shot my special there that [__] was
bonkers dude
uh anyway dude enough i'm not trying to
gloat i'm just trying to tell you i'm
very very appreciative and i'm very
grateful and you guys [__] came out
and i will be hitting atlanta and
washington dc and stockton for some
reason and oakland and peoria for some
reason and rockford for illinois for
some reason uh so go to chrisley.com get
your tickets and i can't wait to go dude
um and i will putting out be putting out
vlogs for all these dude because i'm
having a [__] good time dude and i
want to i want to share the experience
with you guys
um we flew from dallas
okay so we had to take wichita
flight back to dallas and then dallas
back to lax
and dude we get to the airport in dallas
when when we're we're from from kansas
and dude i get there and i look and
there's [__] homies you know what i
mean just like homies like when a when a
group is together at an airport
you see them and you're like oh i like
that they're traveling all together but
these were all dressed in black
all homies and there were like eight of
them right and i look at one of them
they all got masks on now i'm like okay
if you have masks on in lax
right
i don't even really think i don't really
you know
la is very woke right so if you're going
to wear masks a lot of mass in the
airport right that's okay you're woke
and that's fine it shouldn't be a
political thing if you feel comfortable
wearing a mask inside great more power
to you i think you should i want you to
be comfortable right okay now if you see
masks in dallas airport
something like is different right so i'm
like why are these guys wearing a mask
why why are the homies wearing a mask
right why are these eight homies wearing
masks
because if you see a homies wearing
in dallas
you think okay well yeah sure we are
flying to los angeles so maybe they're
woke but also maybe some extras going on
here
so i do my [__] thing you know how uh
who's the [__] detective uh watson
and sherlock holmes i do my thing where
i quickly gather all the information
just by taking a [__] wide shot of
the people right you ever do that you
ever try to feel information right
because you can do that dude that's the
gift of fear you ever read that book
it's amazing it's about intuition more
specifically women's intuition but i
have women's intuition okay
my i don't we don't label my intuition
my intuition i identify as a woman all
right so my intuition as a woman takes a
wide snapshot of these guys and i
immediately go to oh
this is a hip-hop group now am i racist
we don't know but none of the guys are
black so maybe not but they are maybe
all not white like maybe they're mexican
or cute i don't know what they are
they're not black they're cuban there's
something but i take the snapshot
i take the intuition snapshot
and i decide they're a hip-hop group now
am i racist now what do i do and the
reason why i'm wondering about this is
because maybe they're not wearing the
masks out of wokeness maybe they're
wearing the masks because of why well
they have hoods on they all have
sunglasses on maybe they're doing it to
try to disguise their face which is what
i should be doing because it's super
annoying when people come up to me at
the airport and ask for pictures and
then take videos now
yes for a pick why'd you take a vid all
good yes for one thing
not the other i acquiesced and now i'm
stuck on video looking like a [__]
[__] and i gotta smile
so i judge maybe they're famous
and i just maybe they're a hip-hop group
now i'm not racist
but i do a little bit more of i take
more than just the intuition snapshot i
take more than
that i look at them and i decide
i'm 80 sure that they're [__] cypress
hill okay
i'm 80 sure that they're cypress hill
so i go
maybe that's be real
maybe that's sendog i've got no idea
is it send dog and be real i don't know
i walk over to my tour manager
he says just see cypress hills here and
i go ch ching and i know it's cypress
hill number one
because i thought it was cypress hill
and my tour manager said did you see
cyprus hill over there but mostly
because
my tour manager is mexican
now that was too soft the runner we
needed a little bit
there we go dude
now he's mexican so he knows right
because i have mexican and also like for
some reason persians love cyprus hill
but and they and they and i have
personal friends that love cypress hill
and dude it was cypress [__] hill and
um
i'm like am i going to become friends
with
be
am i going to become friends with be
real dude
there is something you can't understand
what could just kill a man the two
opposite ends of voices and two [__]
lines there is something you can't
understand hawaii could just kill a man
two opposite ends dude
they really had i didn't know they had
so many [__] hits though dude
they're they're their songs are so
cinematic dude their songs are so
cinematic they're in so many movies
remember this one i want to get high
so high
remember that one remember this one i'm
having illusions
whatever the [__] remember that one so
many [__] good songs man they really
did dude that one and [__] um
there was another song called lowrider
what what's the [__] and then uh
cyprus
i'm having the illusions and the
preducions and the bleak flicks and the
rhymes what else dude uh songs cypress
hill songs
are they from cypress or some [__] um
this one where the [__] insane and
the membrane insane in the brain and
then it goes insane in the mic and then
i gotta go
insane because i got no brain dude so
like [__] high making that song
insane because you got no brain wouldn't
be insane would just be [__] on a
pile of skin on the floor
and then that [__] plankton
live large buy your house five cars and
you're in charge coming up in the world
ever if you don't know that song you're
[__] you got no brain
dude that song was [__]
blank
dude i'm so good at hitting those notes
it's unbelievable you know exactly what
i'm [__] doing when i go
so you wanna be in rock superstar
if you don't know that song you got no
brain
so yeah dude
it's killer [__] so now i'm like am i
gonna be friends with be real and also
i'm like we're sendog and for some
reason i got in the back of my head that
send dog quit the group i have no idea
but there was another guy that looked
like he was cuban and it could have been
send dog and that's when i knew i was
racist still not sure if it's sundog and
they're all sitting dude here's the
thing about cyprus still you want some
inside info on cypress oil because i
have it dude
there was like eight of them
all dressed the same
all in black
looking real cool
they were all either in first class or
the one right behind it like with the
plus [__]
and i'm telling you dude there were
eight of them
during the whole flight from dallas to
[__] la
none of them said one word to each other
if that's not the most
cypress hiliar ass [__] that you've ever
heard
they didn't say one word to each other
dude
and calvin
had a crying fit in front of the
real
sat in front of be real and we my son
had two cups of water and kept on
putting one the [__] water in one cup
and a water in another cup water and one
cup watering another cup and i was
overseeing the operation obviously
because this is going to [__] end in
a travesty and i'm like i'm gonna do it
until he spills a little dude
dude he kept doing it keeps doing it and
then he spilled a lot all over his
[__] pants dude
and it was annoying as [__] match
because now he can't change his pants
because they're packed and we only have
one diaper right
and so i went to go so i go all right
that's enough and then chris was like
that's enough and then she gave the cups
to throw away to the [__]
air stewardess to throw away
and um
and then and then calvin just starts
crying so hard and right he was sat
right in front of be real and he was
[__] crying so hard dude he was like
i need the cops
but i kept on sneaking looks back to be
real and if that guy was and maybe
whoever that guy was that was maybe
sendog
and he was just [__] crying dude
and i was like calvin you can't just
you're gonna get wet dude you're gonna
keep getting wet
it's like stop being [__] insane in
the membrane dude calvin can you stop
being insane in the membrane
you're being insane because you got no
brain
kevin's been throwing some fits lately
it took a while it's one of the terrible
twos my pediatrician said it was it's
supposed to be from one to two but i
have a feeling with calvin's gonna be
from two and a half to three and a half
or maybe just two and a half on my
terrible twos are still happening so
um i'm having an illusion symphony
illusions and everybody
dude [__] um
i love that [__] remember that was
that training day
evil wolf or sheep
um
super fun dude
so my son's basically in cyprus hill
it's basically what i mean they flew
with them
can't see [__] all good
i got the best fans though man i really
do
i got the best fans in
wait no in dallas
uh there was this artist guy that
drew me pictures of me and also calvin
and peppa pig together and then also
calvin i have to put his instagram
handle up here somewhere i gotta
remember it but i reposted his [__] he
also brought
an oop and oops
uh
painted oops i put on my instagram story
but a painted oops grenade with my face
on it and it's a grenade that says oops
and it's it's like a heavy real grenade
thing you know and then uh
and it was there when i got to dallas
and i was like oh yeah this guy said he
was gonna bring it by and he did this is
awesome how cool and i met him in the
meet and greet super nice guy him and
his lady they're [__] beautiful
just their souls are just [__]
beautiful right i don't really say that
by by many people
but uh why i just don't even say that
right because i'm not the kind of guy
who says like you have a beautiful soul
cause who the [__] am i jason moraz you
know and um
mr a to the z so corny so um
and so uh
when i found out it was jason mraz was
mr a to z that was like [__] holy
[__] talk about we mean i was like this
for about a day and a half
so uh i'm there and the [__] the
pictures are there of calvin and peppa
pig and then also just a picture of me
doing stand up and then another picture
of something else i can't remember but i
have it and um
and the oops grenade and then i'm like
very cool now
my my ex is hitting me up saying you
know she lives in dallas and she's like
hey we want to come to the show
uh and i was like hell yeah come to the
show set them up with tickets you know
we're still friends we're still good and
um
and uh and she comes to the show and
she's like do you want coffee and i was
like [__] you know what i actually
didn't ask anyone to get me a coffee
that would be beautiful she was like
i'll get you for whatever you encouraged
krista wants and i was like you give me
this and this and she said okay cool
and then she calls me as i'm getting
into the to getting to the theater and
she's like hey they won't let me in
because i don't know they're being the
security's being real strict they won't
let me in because of the um
the coffees and they won't let liquids
in and i was like oh okay and i was like
hey buddy
enrique can you go grab them and just
get your little man here sorry you know
you give me the coffees and i give
kristen the coffee i was like that's so
nice of you thank you so much i hadn't
seen her a long time get big hugs she
met calvin and all that [__]
and i'm drinking the coffee and i'm like
yeah it's [__] i guess they don't
want the liquid in the thing you know i
guess they want to [__] make money
from their concession stand
and then i stop and i think hey but wait
though
they were cool with a real grenade in my
dressing room
they can't bring liquids in
but they brought artillery
dude it's a real grenade
and then kristen is like he gave you a
grenade and i'm like yeah isn't this
cool and she goes no
and i was like what do you mean look at
the art and she says is it real and i
was like well they probably took the
[__] out right and she says
how do you know and i was like oh
yeah you're right and they won't let a
starbucks in and then i thought about
wait a second i can't bring this on the
plane though
because you can't do it somebody tried
to do it in oklahoma city and the whole
airport got shut down it was another
famous guy i can't remember and i say
another famous guy because they're both
famous because yeah i'm famous deal with
it dude
so i left a grenade in the [__] room
in the dressing room and whoever play is
playing their next like david gray
whoever the [__] it is is going to get
it so david gray enjoy your oops grenade
and i loved it i wanted to take it back
but i can't take it back can you even
mail a real grenade how do you get a
grenade from one place to another you
got to use the military right
i don't know man probably some backdoor
[__] but i will tell you dude it was you
know the
i couldn't bring it back but i loved it
but i took a video of it so thank you
very much for the oops grenade and
you're probably listening because i
think you listen to all the episodes you
were saying because i met him at the
meet and greet
uh and uh thank you so much for your
artwork i got the peppa big drawing i
got the me drawing and i got there's
another drawing i can't remember what it
is i can't place it i think it was also
of me but um
yeah and i didn't bring the grenade but
we have that moment together don't we
yep and i was holding the grenade and
then i was like wait a minute this could
blow up at any time and then i put it
[__] kind of in the corner whatever
under a pillow um you know what i mean
so that's good i'm still hunting in the
headphones anyway though [__] [__]
yeah dude i'm still hot what you did
earlier didn't you affect it at all so
that's awesome dude thanks a lot one
fire yeah oh is that the right there we
go there we go that's it [__] yeah dude
it didn't work the first time i did the
second time that's amazing dude what he
did the first time literally didn't
change it one iota and it's all good
though
um
so yeah i got that [__] uh the oops i
wish i had the oops grenade i wish i did
honestly
crazy
[Music]
and now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp uh look there are plenty of
ways to support a healthy brain like
learning a new language or taking power
naps you know there's exercise there's a
bunch of things but there's also better
help online therapy uh i do therapy
to be quite honest it saved it helped
save my life man um you know mental
health is a really important thing uh
that you need to take care of and it's a
struggle for a lot of people it's been a
struggle for me uh and it continues to
be uh i have very bad ocd and anxiety
and therapy i think is a is a great way
to take care of your mental health and
um i think that you take care of your
car by bringing it into the shop you got
to do therapy to take care of your brain
uh maintenance it's all about
maintenance better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
the live chat therapy session so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to if you feel any type
of way about it uh it's great it's much
more affordable here at betterhelp than
in-person therapy and it's also easier
to get to because you just do it on on
this
on betterhelp uh you could be matched
with an uh with a therapist in under 48
hours that's very quickly it's very hard
to find a therapist usually anyway our
listeners here of congratulations get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
congratulations that's better help
congratulations so if you support the
show and you're into maintaining your
mental health go here better help thank
you
[Music]
boy i've got some good advice oh
not gonna be
oh dude matthew mcconaughey well i've
got some good advice
also
let us decide you know boy i've got some
good advice you know why because i was
an interstellar
like this is the [__]
these actors and [__] musicians dude
well i've got some good advice
you know why
i was in sahara
well i got some good advice
you know why i was in 10 things but lose
about a date or whatever the [__] that
movie is
10 ways to kill a man on a date or
whatever the [__] it is
but i got some good advice you know why
i wasn't [__]
happy and dazed or whatever the [__]
that dazed and confused
happy in days to do it
i wasn't confused and deluded man
well i got some good ass
so
wow
back in time and save the world right
there let's do it again went back in
time and saved the world and that's in
that went to the future and saved the
world right here
well i've got some good advice went to
the future saved all of mankind came
back and started talking so
my college roommate samuel monroe will
hey dude his whistle of the s dude it's
like the [__] pedophile and family
guy with the dog
home
for christmas break
and he was at his he was at his great
grandpappy's house oh man he's really
milking the texas [__] with the crap mr
monroe wills was 94 years old and he
said it's so texting to be so old too
you know like it's so texting to be like
yeah and he was 94 years old man
boy and boy he survived a lot of [__]
man
and i'll tell you too he
chewed tobacco every single day since he
was nine and i think he just [__]
got by with willpower you know i think
he'd be cancer just with his mind he
said he said can you give me some advice
for life as grandpa says also this story
is such utter horseshit
none of these people exist
i mean you know
well let's listen let's do it
uninterrupted i'm sorry about
interrupting it well i've got some good
boy started with boy
so
my college roommate samuel monroe was
filming a home
three names christmas break
and he was at his he was at his great
grandpappy so drunk his great grandpappy
mr monroe will's making it up for years
old and he said grandpappy he said he
said can you give me some advice for
life and his grandpappa says oh yeah
money
that's advice i can give you this acting
acting
i've had many crisises in my life
most of them
never happened
oh he walked away dude he should have
moonwalked i mean that little only
[__] more [__] thing ow dude
what does it mean i know what it means
but what does it mean dude
most of them never happened
[Laughter]
dude
this is an insane person
loves to hear the sound of his voice
unbelievable dude none of this ever
happened at all none of it happened at
all that's the best part
so
my college roommate samuel monroe wills
went home
for christmas break
and he was at his he was at his great
grandpappy's house and his
great-grandpappy
mr monroe wills was 94 years old and he
said grandpappy said he said can you
give me some advice for life and his
grandparents says oh yeah money
jay-z best advice i can give you is this
jay-z
i've had many crisises in my life
most of them
never happened
[Laughter]
jay-z yeah dude
most of them never happened bill clinton
dude
that's actually very powerful um
so yeah but dude that's crazy man
matthew mcconaughey always wearing the
same [__] thing dude how about how
much did he [__] film
40 of these in 2018
and he's rolling him out doing it
wow man he's just rolling him out and he
forgets about him for months at a time
why don't we post one of the you know we
got to start doing more of is posting
more of those things when i when i wore
that um americana outfit right because
we we need to get on that man i don't
think that could be something you know
where'd he go
you know i would tell those [__]
stories
you know
unbelievable dude matthew mcconaughey
loves to hear him i've never heard
actors are [__] so annoying huh man
imagine going to dinner with [__]
matthew mcconaughey
tom cruise like mel gibson and [__]
you know
i don't know denzel or something you
would be like oh for [__] sake dude
hey guys
shut the [__] up huh
hey guys real quick you guys are all
[__] complete [__]
[Laughter]
um anyway
well i got some good advice
i should talk to you guys about this man
my [__] uh
so you know me dude
i'm not really into drugs and [__] i
don't do drugs
i got this company that [__] sent me
some cbd [__] and they were like try
this [__] or fans i was like i'll try it
what does it help with and they were
like it helps with anxiety helps with
[__] um
they know i have restless leg syndrome
and they know the only thing that helps
my restless leg syndrome you know is
squirting right i gotta squirt and then
it goes it [__] releases some
serotonin
i squirt i go to bed i can't my my legs
like i'm dancing my foot loose right
before i go down i can't go to sleep
because my legs are activated but if i
squirt it's fine i don't want to squirt
all the time though dude you know what i
mean
so they're like start taking this cbd
every day you won't have russell's type
syndrome i was like [__] did it
go on dude it took a few weeks restless
leg syndrome gone i drop it under my
tongue gone dude i don't need to squirt
i can squirt if i want to but now i'm
just squirting for fun besides that gone
i don't need to squirt if i want now i'm
squirting not for function for fun
all right
anxiety level down dude all right
and your boys had bumps in the road
but boy he's
smooth on the [__] you know it's like
he's got one of those lexuses right just
[__] yeah i feel the bumps but do
they really matter
lift the tongue up
drop it under
and i got some gummies roll them if i
need it you know
right
so i was talking this company and it
really helped my restless leg syndrome
and it leveled down my anxiety so what i
want to do is i want to
tell you guys that you i'll put the link
under below
uh but click it
look at their website if you deal with
any of these [__] issues there's so
many one you know people say [__] like
it cures cancer which i don't know if
that's horse [__] or not but all i can
tell you is for me restless leg syndrome
i don't have to squirt anymore i'm
squirting for fun not function and also
anxiety leveled down so you can uh click
the link and then uh you get a
10 off code uh for and it's uh congrats
there so i'll put the url under it um
i don't know man it's just like i
[__] dude life is hard and [__] and i
just wanted it to be [__] nice
and it's it's it's like
you know i i really think mental health
is is is
is is very important and sometimes the
day gets the best of you dude and i just
wanted i was like at a loss i was like
fine i don't like but this the kind i
use doesn't have any thc in it it just
has [__] cbd so it's awesome anyway
um
you guys should try it so go to the link
and use it and you can get a
[__] off and congrats and um
anyway
that's that
life's hard
but it's all good though isn't it
life does get hard doesn't it
can't see wonder if it'll help from my
scene
um
this [__] jeremy fragrance dude
is just insane
is this guy like
how long does a guy like the smell of
bread
oh it smells so good you know it's bread
like this guys
he looks like one of those [__]
muscle mannequins how does red smell
in bio class
well this already
went bad this is honestly what you you
imagine yourself tied up with like
gagged kidnapped and you know he's gonna
kill you this is the [__] he says the
smell of bread
oh the smell of bread bread oh this look
at all this bag of bread and you're just
like
[Music]
right here
you know your life's going to end in
within 25 minutes deep rich earthy
no you're going to die
like hey guy oh does the
bun smell oh just dead in [__] 18
minutes just made it
oh
stuffing his face with the bread you
know you're not more like paper kind of
okay you know you're dead in nine
minutes straight up so if i would have
to describe the smell of bread takes out
a knife just
it would be
audition tape this was the audition tape
for his hannibal lecter they're doing a
remake and this is the audition tape
deep rich earthy
oh and i was jump roping so [__] the
way he's doing it dude
the smell of bread
oh it smells so good
this is the audio they took out the
smell of bread look at this guys
how does bread smell
how does bread you haven't eaten in
three days and you know you're gonna die
90 minutes well this already
went bad whoa
[Applause]
it smells
deep rich earthy
and the music in the background
the most
this is the most euro trash video i've
ever seen in my life
he's so high on ecstasy and like they
don't use mali anymore it's more like
paper kind of
so if i would have to describe the smell
of bread the jump roping thing is the
thing that seals the deal
it would be
crush i mean so stale the bread why
deep rich earthy
no that was weird how could it be any
weirder oh that's how
just [__]
that guy how long does a guy like that
have you know you got to keep up in the
game that's why you got to hand it to
[__] uh
dj khaled it's like you can't really be
famous for the [__] anymore you got to
be famous for the personality like like
like kanye is not famous for his [__]
for anything but being kanye
you know
drake has to do a [__] what's that
song hotline bling you know his music's
fine but did you listen to his last
album could you name one song i can't
he's gotta do do being memes and [__]
you got to get to that level where
you're just in memes you know what i'm
talking about otherwise you ain't [__]
dude
ryan reynolds had a new [__] show
came out nobody gives a [__]
you know
you got to be in memes bro you got to be
a [__] meme god you got to be in you
got to have a picture like this
and have a meme with it and be like when
your son takes your tomatoes
or whatever the [__] dude otherwise you
ain't [__] dude
fame is old unless you're like you can
be harrison ford or
you know you could you know anybody like
will smith who's the last movie star
leonardo dicaprio maybe ryan gosling is
working maybe maybe maybe him but ryan
gosling got a key he's got to keep going
like this barbie movie if it tanks which
you know i guess it won't cause his
barbie but if it tanks bro
uh what's his name ryan gosling you
gotta you gotta get meme level famous
man
that's what happened to you know
keanu reeves or some [__] the people
started talking about him on the
internet you got to be meme level dude
anyway
chris rock said no he's not going to
[__] do the oscars anymore they asked
him to come back to host it of course
and he said no
um
and i think that that's good chris rock
says he was invited to host 2012 oscars
and he turned the offer down um
he told a crowd in phoenix stand-up show
that he was offered to return to the
oscars in 2023
and he said no
um
yeah i don't know man i guess that's
cool i don't know man i mean well of
course they want him to do it you know
the ratings this is the sh this is the
[__] i'm talking about it needs to you
need to level up the [__] nobody's
watching the oscars because [__]
francis mcdormand was in a movie where
she walked around a park for two and a
half hours you know you gotta [__]
like nobody gives you [__] you're not
even giving awards to the people that
the movies are [__] watching right
give nine awards to chris evans right
give nine awards to [__] marv
marv rucklow
or or or or what
you're not giving [__] nine awards to
goddamn zendaya then nobody gives a [__]
oh whoa that's cool the [__] uh the
the lady from uh
the the the
the help is
she was in a movie and and she's going
to be
you know oh you're giving her nobody
gives a [__]
right
okay blanchett played another queen
uh well she played someone ugly by
putting glasses on let's get or give her
a nomination and some french guy that's
black because he's [__] you know oh
nobody gives a [__]
give denzel washington not no not even
give [__]
it's gotta be you gotta give give uh
zendaya all awards otherwise nobody
gives a [__]
nobody cares dude nobody's watching the
oscars you got to let some
let it you want someone to watch the
oscars let a kangaroo loose on [__]
stage and murder meryl streep
views
otherwise no views dude
make a challenge
do a [__] kangaroo kill star
challenge this oscar meryl streep is
getting let she's going to present best
actress with a kangaroo
we give the kangaroo
a bunch of barbed wire and just see what
happens
just metal strip all cut up
nobody's watching this [__]
i mean like nobody nobody gives a [__]
about the oscars when there's
chicks shaking their [__] shits on
tick tock
right
all the all the all the
chicks with the [__] just it's
starting every video like this hey guys
dude
every video the chicks from instagram
reels they start the video like this hey
guys so their tits [__] bounce you
know and you're just like wait what
they're talking about what
hey guys i'm on you you know hey guys so
i saw the movie nope and here's my
review and you're like
all right well let's see
let's see maybe i'll see that movie or
i think that's what i care about here
so i don't know i don't think that
[__] chris rock i i you know your
help
honestly
40 million dollars that's what i do it
for
otherwise not into it
for him dude he's got more money than
[__] god so whatever
jesus died with no money but you know
what i mean bro
this guy is you know how they say
this guy
at the ball game
[Music]
the guy [__]
sticks a pen
in the middle of a [__] hot dog
through it
and then sticks his hot dog in the beer
and drinks it out of a
like it's a straw the beer the hot dog
bro hey guy you're the grossest guy in
the world wearing a plaid new york
yankees hat
this is the grossest thing i've ever
seen in my life
and doing it like it's something to do
with the black [__] panda dunks on
of course someone's recording this like
right away i would be like what the
[__] this guy doing
ew dude hot dog beer
gross dude everyone's so gross you ever
see someone
you ever look at someone's lips like for
real like when they're talking like
outside
in the summer you're just like ew
it's all pink in their [__] mouth and
[__]
ew dude
um
here's something that just was the most
like
shaggy and scooby-doo
bustin
the answer shaggy scooby-doo
thinks it's good to do a [__]
scooby-doo impression
[Applause]
that's crazy
i have just one thing to say to you
[Music]
oh wow looked in his eyes and did it
eight thousand dollars
if you did that to me straight up i'd be
like this
i'm sorry
i i just i it was a [__] guttural
thing i don't know i'm so sorry pat
sajak
just
i've only got one thing to say to you or
oh my god i'm uh
mr sajak i'm so sorry i i just i i don't
need my 8 000 i'm going to go
just [__] pop him like that in his
ear here we go
oh i'm sorry you should have done that
goddamn scooby-doo person i i am my bad
i i don't need my 8 000
so you want to be a rock superstar live
large rock ross one
one time i was doing like this i was
doing like this in school i was doing i
was bouncing up and down on my seat at
school it was in [__] um science
class i was going like this and the guy
behind me said what are you sitting on
and i [__] always think of that
dude and i always think of that man
because he got me good dude i was
bouncing and he was acting like i was
[__] jumping on something you know
what i mean can't say it cause little
age restrict me here on youtube but
did i not talk about this mediterra doc
i already did
mancheteo
i did already
wow one fire [__] super one fire
thrown out topics already did can't see
[__] all good dude
all right let's do some deserved scales
uh see what the dessert scale is on
these here
got a bunch of them here uh sharing a
drink over a balcony doesn't work out
perfectly here we go oh wow okay so two
chicks and bikinis and you know when
that's gonna happen it's trouble
especially if one of their bags is a
zebra a zebra prince so um guys trying
to let's see what happens let's go back
oh
[__] dude
killed her
the guy's name is austin
okay hold on a second dude this chick
just goes like this
obviously a position she's been in him
plenty before
and
she is waiting for a guy to pour a drink
from the balcony to her and he's using a
[__] one of those igloo things with
the things you press like this and fill
the water in it is huge one of the
things one of those uh gatorade things
that that players dump the coach over
the super bowl that's how big it is
and the guy just basically
goes to dump it and just drops the whole
thing on
her head
[Applause]
let's watch this again
oh it just goes thump she's so drunk her
reaction time is absolutely minimal dude
she just goes like this
gunk like
from two stories up and it
oh man it was so heavy it's so filled
with liquid right and then the guy goes
austin dude wow a guy named austin every
man named austin 80 of austin's have
done something stupid like this
[Music]
best part is at the
very end dude he said all right let's go
get more
[Laughter]
just no regard for this [__] chick
roger just listen to the
[Music]
such a dick cold-hearted
dick dude
gives austin [__] for doing it let's go
get more let's go bunk some chicks on
the head more with some more [__]
dude this is that honestly she didn't
really deserve that so i can't say
deserve a skill for her but still was
high hilarity so let's give it a five i
mean she shouldn't be she was drunk so
let's not be looking up at strangers
doing this
anytime you look up at strangers doing
that you're in big you're for a big big
big hurt okay so
uh that's a five out of the deserved
scale what to do when here's another one
what to do when a hognose snake bites
you okay
what could it mean let's listen and
watch here we go so everybody in the
comments i noticed was asking
what do you do
when she bites you oh [__] this is
sunflower
my hognose she's a red albino and she
just likes to bite taking the snake out
all the time see
just like that
so
to get her off cute little thing about
these hognose snakes you see that little
scale on the front why are you letting
me take their little nose like that and
you kind of ah
she's chewing on my knuckle though that
really hurts
but
normally to get her off oh god
one up a whole octave
normally oh she's really on there though
oh oh she's really on me this time oh sh
god hold on
i mean what is the face take two
normally this is a lot easier she's
still on my finger
oh my god the [__] white face what is
it a mask that he's doing what is he
doing a [__] cleansing mask
maybe that's why
dude don't i honestly don't have a snake
dude i used to do a bit about this on my
stand up and i i just i don't really do
it anymore but just don't have a snake
dude like what are you doing let him
[__] out man
one of the jackasses just like with the
snake like britney spears hey guys
remember that guy who used to come to
the school
so a little bit about snakes and he's
always wearing tan for some reason
a little bit about snakes and this is
actually not dangerous hold on hold on
hold on hold on
move from back there move him back there
you want to stay in front of him so a
little bit about snakes hold on hold on
okay so he's got jimmy
here's another desert scale uh standing
on the rope during tug of war wow
dude already a 10 with the title
oh he spun around like a ragdoll dude
i mean 19 people are holding it
oh he spun around thought he was gonna
get a nice [__]
360. did a [__] 1240.
oh the guy went around like a [__]
ragdoll dude
looked like he got hit by a car
it probably it doesn't look like
i mean there's always chicks ruining the
video with screaming and [__]
chicks are always ruining it and [__]
i'm surprised she didn't do it selfie
mode too so we missed a lot of it um
that's a
seven out of ten honestly standing on
the [__] rope
here we go what was the plan that's an
already funny title here we go
here we go here we go here we go guy in
all yellow first of all all yellow
somewhere like
i don't know where let's guess where
this is this is in africa i don't know
where it is
oh
oh my god that's not okay
that is not that is a
that is a sad that guy had such a
promising career for any [__] i mean
the guy literally looked like the
fastest man alive and then just ran face
first into a [__] dodge intrepid
oh my god dude
just
just so fast into a [__]
astro van holy [__] dude i cannot
believe
that one of the guys from cool runnings
did that that is unbelievable all right
here we go i mean that's not i don't
even that we don't rate that one because
don't ever try that that's horrible okay
trying to challenge a referee in a
boxing match holy [__]
the worst song of all time
this was good the
oh oh we bought
oh wow we body centered
oh wow the ref just went nuts oh dude
wow that guy
this is the worst song of all time
nice
oh threw him and goes like threw him
down and goes
like threw deuces up like a [__] g
dude
this guy this ref is a [__] g dude
been spending most our lives living in
the gangster's paradise
been spending most our lives
i sing good all right dude let's look at
some tinders man let's see how shitty
people are on tinder
[Laughter]
dude tinder's terrible hey how's it
going suck it
you know all right here we go uh here's
one wanna make a pillow fort and make
out i've literally
i've probably said the same thing to
somebody uh what happened to hello how
are you the person says
then the guy says am i crazy for
thinking that opening is bland compared
to my cool
am i crazy for thinking that opening is
bland compared to my cool badass opening
involving the creation of a high-tech
fortress
wow
what a loser
you matched my favorite part about this
is you matched with ebony
tinder here we go
next one
good thing my jaw hurts
[__] yeah dude y'all hurts yes can't
even see too [__] can't even see dude
red flags i don't like velcro wallet no
sauce with nuggets i'm all there no
sauce with nuggets bro that's me [__]
we wouldn't get along dayton female best
friend never that uh likes andrew tate
you make some good points um
what is your stance on velcro shoes
andrew tate is a [__] that's
understandable like just female best
friend or female female friends in
general what about green flags i mean
this guy's just taking it way too
seriously bro you lost from jump man
just go ha ha hang
she says i don't know prob is going to
be a no to velcro shoes too female
friends are okay if you don't have a
history and there are boundaries but it
depends
he says i'm a little curious as to why
no velcro is so i mean that guy is
vulgar you know
guy has [__]
the the most velcroist jews that have
ever lived
like has so many [__] like has so
many different pairs and they have four
straps each of them
um
i'm a little curious as to why no velcro
is so high that that's understandable if
they have a complicated or had a
previous relationship i've only got
plutonic female friends anyway she says
probs because they all friend zoned you
i bet you should hit
if given i bet you should hit if given
the chance he says aha interesting
response i think this is where the
conversation ends best of luck in your
future tinder endeavors
is there more or no is that it
wow this guy got [__] walked away in
his velcro shoes wow i got so stung off
the velcro shoe [__] why what's up with
velcro shoes dude
well [__]
you still thinking about them all right
here we go
another one
tinder really shocks me but this guy
all right
my name is chad and i don't give a [__]
i wouldn't mind pounding you from behind
sometime this week
you know of all the [__] names
chad yeah we know chad i don't give a
[__] oh yeah
my name is chad and i don't give a [__]
i wouldn't mind pounding you from behind
sometime this week i can't wait until
the future catches up with everyone and
people who run for president have
[__] messages like this well we kind
of did that already uh ch thanks chad
nice to meet you too i mean why are you
responding
he says you schizophrenic or something i
said i wanted to pound you not nice to
meet you
holy [__]
yes you're correct i'm schizophrenic
he says honestly not surprised at all
i'll still pound you once then ghost you
after so just text me
then they say re wow you really drive a
hard bargain and he says not like you
offer anything of substance between
besides that wet box and don't know when
to shut the [__] up and bring me two
coffees oh
dude why too
such a dick
hey guy
change
and then some then she says i can tell
you're extremely intelligent he says
good thing nobody ever gave a [__] about
what women thought like ever lol
the guy's horrible
and he says oh yeah thank god nobody
does lol she says
wow
oh there's more
unreal okay
but wait
there's more
uh
okay
he says oh you know nobody
does that law he says you're gonna shut
the [__] up and text me or keep wasting
my time i mean he's the one talking
about all this [__] she's i think i'm
probably not gonna test you but i wish
you luck in finding a woman dumb enough
to put up with your god-awful and
borderline frightening attitude
he says nobody gives a [__] what you
think so shut the [__] up jesus christ i
mean so angry dude
nobody likes a disagreeable woman if i
want to date a man i'll go on grindr
you'll die alone cheers
shitty and then so nice with the cheers
so he says have you ever heard andrew
tate i bet you'd really love his contact
he says [__] off go bother someone else
and stop wasting my time
jesus christ dude
it's so much energy to be that shitty
you know
just going on to be shitty
so mad that guy
i guess love doesn't need a language
here we go
i'm yawning because i'm me all right
here we go hey how are you hola
english
espanol
english someone says espanol
and they say sex i say
si
wow
so simple um
i wonder if they thought they meant like
what sex are you
see that's a great slam if you're
honestly mexican and somebody asks you
that
um
did the love language one didn't mark it
off here we go win for the win a win for
the short guys
wow
i'm about to climb okay here we go uh
i limit the age to 30 if i didn't
i wouldn't get i would get if i didn't i
would get so many 20 year olds they
aren't very fun all they want is to do
is [__] like a rabbit i guess that's
what the woman's saying he says yeah
there's a huge difference i mean i still
want to [__] like a rabbit but i want to
do other things too exactly how tall are
you that's good dude that's good that he
said i still want to do that
but
you know
um
how tall you he says five six if that's
too short for you it's fine lol she says
seriously lol i'm 6'1 he says i know
some women have preferences and i oh wow
i really would be like a rabbit [__]
you wow that's hilarious dude
yeah
um i would be like a rabbit [__] you
um
and then she says i just tend to get
really short guys wink
and then he says well are you down for
it because i'm still taller than you on
your back and or knees she says you're
so funny when are you
is there more
when were you thinking dude the guy's
sure but he do really be spitting that
game hey what's up i really would be
like a rabbit
wow that's amazing dude guy killed it
see
personality is killer dude the guy was
funny as [__]
i really would be like a rabbit [__]
you
here we go here's another one oh here we
go click to see
because it's not safe for work
hey how's it going oh hey just planting
too many seeds for too small a garden
lol wow that's funny as [__] actually i
love that i need to do the same
he's and then he say i can't stop buying
heirloom tomatoes
okay so boring
getting on the boring side but uh then
they say [__] i love fresh tomatoes with
salt or fresh mozzarella and basil that
would make me
that would make me calm
dude
ruined it well it did spice things up
though huh
oh tomato with salt makes me [__] dude
what's up tomatoes ah we got salt on it
yeah
oh wow that's so good man love that one
all right guys well that's it for
congratulations this week i really
appreciate you guys um i'm out dude i'm
out and i will be in washington dc
and atlanta it's sold out and then i
will be in stockton california and then
i will also be in uh
oakland california
and then i will be in peoria and
rockford illinois for some reason
i'm gonna go do this uh i'm gonna eat
some spectrum some pure spectrum gummies
that's a cbd i was telling you about so
going over to pure spectrum
uh going over to the link below
on uh on my comments and uh
put in the code congrats
for your 10 off this it helped me with
my russell's leg syndrome and my anxiety
um so you guys are great dude thank you
very much and i really appreciate you
keep listening and subscribe and like
[Music]
hey guys that's it for youtube uh thanks
for listening and thanks for watching
and uh if you want to catch the rest of
the episode the raw the uncut episode
the ad free episode all you got to do is
go on over to the patreon
patreon.comcrystalia
and uh it's six dollars a month and for
that you get behind-the-scenes footage
of my tour you get a discord you also
get a discord where we chat you also get
um uh an episode an extra episode a
month right now i think there's like 16
on there so if you get it now you binge
all those 16.
uh so that's patreon.comcrystalia
and uh thanks you guys are great